the Joe Rogan experience why don't you
get reading I was reading something that
I was writing this bit about a real
thing that happened with the CIA in the
1950s and it's called operation midnight
climax and I you know MKULTRA Eddie
knows that is a mind-control experience
from the experiments from the CIA they
had 6% of the CIA's budget and there
there was no no oversight they could
spend it on whatever they wanted and
what they were doing is just dosing the
[ __ ] out of people with LSD they dosed
this one guy 77 days in a row she's they
ran out of people that were willing to
do it because a lot of times it was
college students like that's how they
toasted the Unabomber
that's where the answer came from well a
lot of these people they cooked their
brain with acid well they did that with
they ran out of people so they started
opening up brothels so they'd open up
[ __ ] houses and they called it
operation midnight climax mm-hmm so they
would hire hookers and the hookers would
dose these guys up they've give him a
drink
that was filled with acid and then [ __ ]
him and then [ __ ] him on film how much
did they charge was great gage he had
sex and so they would film it through
like two-way glass Wow
yeah and so they're they're sitting
there their whole budget was being spent
on dosing guys and watching guys [ __ ]
fantastic it's hilarious USA I mean they
did it for a lot CIA chief deplores CIA
brothels what year is this that looks
like 1952 77 more than 20 years I was
reading a book on this stuff and when
they were dosed and ruined the LSD and
acid on stuff in haight-ashbury in San
Francisco that's where Manson Canada is
the whole family came out there that was
Steve with the CIA and stuff
okay so ended years ago yeah ended 12
years ago without Ian telling you bro
they're all past history Turner said in
San Francisco the CIA so the CIA had
said that was terrible and that's past
history we don't do that anymore it's
been 12 years away bring up old
checkpoint [ __ ] this is just the tip
of the iceberg we can go on for five
hours with this [ __ ] it's almost like
the CIA
was created as the scapegoat like all
cuz the CIA ain't going to jail where
this how do you put CIA in jail you
can't
and then the directors they're only
there temporarily there and out everyone
like goes through it but it's a read
like if you find out some evil shits
going on
CIA I did it Siang everyone says the CIA
is very acid you know doing all this
crazy [ __ ]
Eddie's one step ahead of us on those
two every time catches informed is all
you do I know you would love to stay I'm
reading a book now we're say hired to
mafia guys to assassinate Castro it's a
legit was legit like plot yes whole plot
knowledge think it's like 635 tries on
his life yeah amazing that was a beast
something like he died of old age yeah
he's right even he even came to New York
yeah and they still gonna do [ __ ] though
yeah that was before they really turned
on him cuz at first the United States
was was backing it yep and they read
Hamlet and then something happened they
switched there's a lot of different
theories like maybe he was working for
that like Fidel Castro was part of a CIA
operation overthrow the Batista regime
maybe or and then like once he got in he
said [ __ ] the CIA [ __ ] the United States
and the CIA goes okay we got to kill
this [ __ ]
a lot a lot of times that happens people
turn you know what I mean some like the
Kennedys turns solve in LA cuz kick the
Kennedys in from a crime family the mom
clique or entity in there - yeah
something happened between Robert and
John were there you know that was his
attorney general that's who he hired so
once they got together something
happened and made them flip some people
say that JFK I don't know if it's true
or not like his son died at a early age
as one of his kids died and that from
that point on he decided to do the right
thing and just say [ __ ] it Simon Robbin
him and Robert knew they were gonna get
killed like they would talk about it
they knew they were gonna get killed for
doing what they're doing but they're
just gonna go out with their boots on
you know what I mean
that's a theory I don't know maybe one
crazy dude did it but
[Applause]